alan goodman keeps his water bucket
filled to the brim
his home's in the village of everton in
bedfordshire and nearly every week the
taps run dry
you turn the taps on in the morning and
there'd be nothing
uh sometimes you'd turn the taps on and
be low water pressure so not enough to
have a shower
barely enough to fill a kettle maybe if
you if you're lucky
everton is in the driest part of the
country the land here looks bleached and
barren and that's bad news for local
farmers
these carrots they normally would be
nice and firm and standing up and remain
like that three to four days whereas you
can see that they are not too happy
doreen gurney's from a family that's
been farming here for seven generations
she remembers the drought of 1976
but says this year is far worse
so here we are we are in drought
conditions and
we can only irrigate about 25 minutes at
a time and then we have to stop it and
it takes an hour and a half for enough
to build up again
dorian says this summer feels like a
nightmare
the problem here is the village is high
up and it is right at the edge of the
water supply line add a drought into the
mix and you can see why there are real
issues with water
the water company here anglian water
says demand is incredibly high and
there's a risk at peak times pressure
may drop they're currently replacing the
mains to improve
water resilience and if you look at
these satellite images of bedfordshire
you can see how much the area has dried
and what's happening in everton
highlights a wider problem one of water
infrastructure and the need for supply
solutions
we are taking water out of out of our
groundwater and out of our reservoirs
that we really need for the future we're
already quite certain that we're going
to need it next summer and yet we're
we're just kind of taking it anyway as
if the future is some distant place that
we'll never have to go so sure there's
an infrastructure problem but one of the
biggest problems is that we're just not
doing the basics of of of limiting water
usage as quickly as possible now
as the hot dry weather continues yet
more fires this one at east tilbury in
essex the extreme heat has brought
difficult and dangerous risks and across
the country
a collective hope that rain is coming
soon laura bundock sky news everton in
bedfordshire